حتى روسيا يعني هي تتدخل احيانا وتتوقف
احيانا كثيره في هذا الموضوع وبالحديث عن
روسيا انت تعتبر ان اي حرب بارده جديده مع
روسيا لن تكون مثل السابقه وانها قد لا
تنتهي على الاطلاق لو سمحت اشرحلنا هذا
المفهوم الذي تتحدث عنه
اذا ما افتكرنا بالحرب البارده بالوقت
المتحده
فكانت نزاع عن ايدولوجيا عالميا بين
الشيوعيا وبين
الاساليب الحره لسياسات والاقتصاديه
والتحسن كانت امبراطوريه متعدده الاوطان
وما عادت موجوده الان الحرب البارده
اعتبرت على انها انتهت رسميا عندما انهار
الاتحاد السوفيتي او اتقسم الى روسيا
وجمهوريه الاخرى هذا لن يحصل مع روسيا
اليوم
وكذلك
ليست منافسه دوليه ايديولوجيه الكل يستطيع
ان يقول ابن الشيوعيه فشلت لانها ما عادت
الدوله الشيوعيه بل هي دوله روسيا طعفت
باشكال كثيره ولكن مع ذلك كما شخص رئيس
بوتين فهي الدوله ذات طموحات امبرياليه
كما اظهره الحرب العدائيه ضد اوكرانيا
ولذلك لا ارى بانها اتينا الحالتين تلك
التي كانت قبل حواليها 35 عاما والتي
نراها الان متشابهه